[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and with the events of chapter
113 of the attack on Titan manga I
believe it is the perfect time to do a
video about Levi's strength so in this
video we will look at all the
information we have available in order
to get a better sense of how strong Levi
actually is if you want to see more
attacks on time videos on this channel
make sure to warhammer smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't
make sure to give that subscribe button
the colossal smash and ring that magic
youtube bell so you don't miss any new
attack on titan content if you like this
type of video I would love to do more
like it for different attack on Titan
characters or even for other anime
characters measuring someone's strength
is always fun especially if that
character happens to be as opie as Levi
we'll also talk about how Levi
ironically went beast mode on the Beast
Titan in the latest chapter later on in
the video if you haven't guessed there
will be beautiful manga spoilers in this
video so this is your last chance to
take the blue pill and get off the ride
now let's get into it as we know Levi is
an acraman so first of all let's take a
look at what we know about the
Ackerman's back in chapter 93 we got
some big news Zeke explained that the
Ackerman's both Levi's and mica sub were
byproducts of titans science so in other
words at this point we learned that the
Ackerman's in one way or another also
possessed the power of the titans
however for a while the details were
left vague there were always signs that
the Ackerman's were special if we
remember back to the training core days
because I've finished at the top of her
class while 2nd 3rd 4th and 5th place
all went to Titan users even yamir the
possessor of the jaw Titan at the time
could have placed higher if she cared
and if she didn't purposely want
historia to make it into the top 10
after Zeke revealed the info about the
Ackerman's it finally made sense why
make us a place so high she too had
access to the power of the Titans it
just manifested differently in her
because she was the byproduct of Titan
science rather than a natural Titan user
then more recently in chapter 112 we got
a lot more juicy details about the
Ackerman's
now keep in mind that this information
is delivered by Aaron who heard it from
Zeke so we never know anything to be
100% certain an attack on Titan but I
assume we all know that by now however
until proven otherwise what Aaron said
to Mikasa is the most useful information
we have Aaron explains that the Ackerman
clan maintained a human form but in some
cases can manifest the power of the
Titans and acraman will go through an
awakening once they recognize someone as
their host this will activate the
instincts in their blood certain
conditions must be met before this
awakening takes place and Aaron suggests
that these conditions are a you must
obey an order and be this must happen
when you are facing death this awakening
heightens and Ackerman's physical
abilities to an extreme but not only
that we get some way more interesting
information - when in acraman awakens
they are given the experience in battle
accumulated by every past acraman by way
of a path very similar to how time users
can remember the past memories of
previous Titan users albeit some users
can remember a lot more than others thus
in theory every subsequent acraman
becomes stronger and stronger since they
keep gaining more and more experience
Levi and Myka some might even benefit
from each other's experience by way of
this path so each one of them might get
stronger every time another gains
additional experience from a fight they
see practices everything because it
builds experience and as if this was the
matrix Levi has had centuries worth of
experience uploaded to him so now we
know why every awakened Ackerman is
powerful now let's take a closer look at
Levi himself let's start by taking a
look at the attack on titan guidebook
inside and out although this was before
the time skip there are some useful
statistics given that can give us more
insight into Levi's strength in combat
he got the highest score and off the
charts 11 out of 10 even Mikasa only got
10 out of 10 now it seems a bit strange
that if they have the same battle
experience passed down from past
sacraments and the same increased
physical strength that Myka saw would be
behind in combat but perhaps it has
something to do with the fact that Myka
saw was 15 at the time and the ability
to fully utilize the experience comes
when the acraman in question becomes a
full-grown adult so the current Myka
who was 19 might currently be an 11 out
of 10 in combat 2
there's some other notable stuff in this
book Levi is as we know refer to as
humanity strongest soldier in the
guidebook it similarly says that he is
the most talented soldier in the survey
Corps we also get a grade for every
character and Levi's is given by Erwin
who gives him an a-plus-plus that's
right two pluses and he says the Levi's
skills are as good as they come Erwin
says that he will always put his trust
and Levi's strengths in regards to his
technique the book says that Levi has
unmatched combat skills and is capable
of techniques that defeat multiple
Titans in the blink of an eye and we've
definitely seen that in another book
called the attack on Titan character
encyclopedia the book explains that
Levi's not only learned how to survive
from Kenny another Ackerman but also
that he surpassed his former teacher now
that we have the guide book and
encyclopedia out of the way let's take a
look at his accomplishments in the manga
first we'll look at the manga special
attack on Titan no regrets it follows
what happened after Kenny abandoned Levi
and before the current events of the
attack on Titan manga a heads up this
manga was drawn by Hikaru Sulu gah and
the story was written by gun snark and
not by isa al-ma himself although it was
an official attack on titan release and
made in cooperation with the attack on
titan production committee so take that
as you will I will talk about this a bit
before going into ISA Alma's main story
because I think any additional
information we can get about Levi can be
useful in this story Levi still an
underground thug managed to get his
hands on vertical maneuvering gear and
even though he wasn't properly trained
Erwin says that Levi uses it with skills
beyond that of a survey Corps veteran
and that his skills cannot be
underestimated so from the beginning
Levi was a natural who taught himself
how to use a vertical maneuvering gear
and quickly exceeded survey corps
veterans in the story Levi has friends
who follow him called
Isabel and for long all three of them
joined the survey Corps and quickly
excel at practice so much so that a
trained soldier is angered that he
trained himself half to death and yet
these three with no soldier experience
are better than him especially in
regards to Levi the soldier comments
that he sold
and that his fighting is flawless
another sees Levi in action and suggests
that he is the wings of the revolution
if that isn't high praise for an early
practice session I don't know what is on
Levi's first mission outside the walls
as a rookie
the first Titan he's ever seen attacks
it isn't abnormal and the other advanced
members of the survey Corps have trouble
taking it down
however Levi as a rookie remains calm
tells Isabel and for lon what to do and
together they take out the Titan with no
issue most people can't believe that a
bunch of rookies could pull it off but
Erlin smiles and thinks that Levi's
wings are the real thing so that was
what happened during the first volume
urlan was so impressed with Levi's
skills that he brought a thug from the
underground and made him a survey corps
member and Levi immediately delivered
quickly showing himself to be better
than everyone else even as a rookie in
vol 2 Erwin comments on how easily Levi
took out the abnormal tight saying it
was brilliant he even calls him a
natural because he defeated an abnormal
Titan on his first expedition so easily
he also suggests that Levi is so good
that having him around makes the others
feel safer levi then reveals that he saw
soldier get eaten by the titan first and
by watching how the titan moved while it
was eating him he figured out how to
fight it this goes to show how quickly
Levi can learn some one's patterns and
figure out a strategy to defeat them
later han she tells Levi that he's given
everyone who saw his fight with the
Titan hope that they don't have to lose
to the Titans if they fight them
correctly which is an absolutely huge
paradigm shift to take place after
viewing one man fight this again speaks
to how special Levi is as a rookie who
managed to learn to use vertical
maneuvering gear by himself he did
something no-one could do before him
make people think that they actually
have a chance of beating the Titans
Isabel also claims that Levi's the
strongest and says that he was even the
strongest in the underground he's number
one she exclaims later on a swarm of
Titan shows up and the conditions are
foggy the Titans managed to defeat and
kill Levi's close friends for lawn and
Isabel which is significant because they
were strong in their own right stronger
than most of the survey Corps
nevertheless
Levi now filled with rage quickly takes
out all of the tight
in the vicinity by himself to the shock
of Erlin who can barely believe that
someone could have defeated so many
Titans at one time we get some
flashbacks from the underground days in
this volume - and it confirms that
despite looking like he has thin arms
Levi can easily defeat men much larger
and more muscular than himself at
armwrestling
so never be fooled by his lack of giant
muscles not only is he a master of
combat his physical strength is also off
the charts so all this happened even
before the main manga took place and it
was clear that Levi even as a rookie was
already the strongest in the underground
and in the survey corps since most
people watching this are somewhat
familiar with the main story I won't
bore you with every single Titan that
Levi kills but I'll focus on some
significant highlights from the manga
that show Levi's strength I remember a
comment on one of my older videos that
went something like this
the walls weren't built to keep the
Titans away from humanity they were
built to keep Levi away from the Titans
the reason why I found this comment so
funny was because it beautifully
captures how strong Levi is in this
world at least in the beginning these
Titans are viewed as the biggest threat
to humanity and yet Levi can take most
Titans pure or abnormal out effortlessly
by himself if the Titans are monsters I
don't know what that makes Levi let's
take a look at how Levi fares against
Titan shifters who are supposed to be
the strongest types of Titans although
you can argue that rod Reese is 120
meter Titan was even harder to deal with
since in that case even Levi couldn't do
much damage on his own against the
female Titan Levi is caught off guard by
the Titans Harding powers that break his
blades the female Titans calls many
Titans to the area using her power and
Levi starts slicing up as many Titans as
possible and in the meantime the female
Titan is able to get away from their
trap after the female Titan reappears
and takes many lives
Levi go Sonic the Hedgehog mode and cuts
up her arm her eye her back and her legs
before she can escape unfortunately
before Levi can finish her off
Mikasa tries to make the finishing blow
at the nape of her neck but gets caught
off-guard by the Titans approaching arm
and Levi in order to say Mikasa hits his
knee off the Titans hand saving because
in the process and injuring
himself so that he is not at 100% for a
while after this moment he nevertheless
cuts opened a Titans mouth and takes
Aaron out and Mika signed him retreat
along with Aaron so the female Titan
could not prevail against him and
there's a chance he would have finished
her off too if he hadn't injured his leg
protecting Mikasa later Levi is able to
get out of a trap set by his uncle the
famous Kenny the Ripper
although Kenny and his men have guns and
equipment more suited to the city and
outnumber Levi greatly Levi still
manages to escape killing some of
Kenny's men along the way
Kenny despite how good he is never
succeeds in defeating Levi and chooses
to die after his dream of inheriting the
founding Titan falls through later at
the showdown during the return to
shigani the ark humanity strongest
soldier Levi faces off against Z who was
called by Reiner Marley's strongest
warrior the beast Titan commands an army
of titans forward but Levi manages to
kill many of his Titans and catch him
off guard he cuts up to be signed so
fast that Zeke doesn't even have time to
harden his skin Zeke is only saved
because Levi wants a survey Corps to
inherit to be sighting power but Peake
shows up in car Titan form and quickly
rescues Zeke despite the fact that the
car Titan is known for its speed levi
manages to catch up to them by using
Zeke's Titans like spider-man uses
buildings Z cannot believe that he was
able to chase them down and calls Levi a
monster Zeke leaves without Berthold and
the colossal Titan because he knows he
cannot defeat leave on making Levi the
clear winner in terms of strength after
that fight back in marl a Zeke tells the
other male officers about the Ackerman's
and shows his fear when he says that he
never wants to meet them again being
able to get such a reaction from Marlay
strongest warrior is quite the
accomplishment and now we've arrived to
chapter 113 the latest chapter as of the
making of this video we had a bit of a
rematch between Zeke and Levi because
Zeke was able to put his spinal fluid in
the wine that the survey Corps drank he
was able to turn everyone watching him
except Levi into Titans so these are all
Levi's soldiers who looked up to him and
turned to him for guidance
Zeke thinks that he is going to be able
to escape because these Titans will keep
Levi busy because there are so many of
them I actually counted as many as 20
tighten surrounding Levi's in one panel
the shoe number alone is a problem but
add to that the fact that all of these
titans used to be Levi's comrades and
you can see why Zeke expected to slowly
buy down he hoped that Levi's emotions
would keep him from killing his former
soldiers or at the very least give Zeke
enough time to get away but nevertheless
Levi catches up to Zeke who transforms
into the beast Titan and even after
defeating all of his former comrades
Levi is able to quickly defeat the beast
Titan this time using the Thunder Spears
to do it now that Levi has thunder
spears Zeke is even less of a match
against them than he was before
and even then Levi crushed him in this
chapter Levi proved that his combat
ability will not be affected or weakened
by his emotions even if he has to kill
his subordinates he will do it if it has
to be done in order to carry out his
mission this is also a factor that we
must take into account when asking
ourselves how strong is Levi because
there are many people who could be
distracted and weakened by their
emotions in the heat of battle but we've
seen that Levi is not one of them so how
strong is Levi given all the evidence we
have I don't think it's a stretch to
call him the strongest living human in
the world of attack on titan that we've
met so far as we've seen titans even
skill Titan shifters are not a match for
him he defeated Marley's strongest
warrior Zeke multiple times without any
trouble when the survey Corps attacked
Marlay the jaw Titan user Porco saw Levi
mokou-san called them the real devils of
parodies to him
they were scarier than any Titan Mikasa
is up there with Levi she effectively
fought against the Warhammer Titan and
the jaw Titan when she was assisting
Aaron Aaron is now very strong himself
he possesses the attack Titan the
Warhammer tight and the founding Titan
but he cannot use the founding Titan
powers on his own so without the help of
Zeke a Titan with royal blood
Eren cannot use the founding Titan power
and he's left with the attack time power
and the Warhammer Titan power at this
point
Aaron's extremely strong but I still
wouldn't put him ahead of Levi the only
person who would probably give Levi
trouble is Armin and his colossal Titan
ability although it is unlikely that the
two will fight each other the colossal
Titan is so opie that Levi would have to
stay at a distance and wait for the
trance
information to run out and then swoop in
and defeat the user the colossal Titan
can cause a massive explosion when he
transforms which can catch enemies
off-guard also as we saw he can
consistently shoot out steam from his
body which will burn any human that gets
close to him so Levi's best bet would be
to wait luckily for him because the
colossal Titan is so overpowered it also
doesn't have the stamina that other
Titans have the colossal Titan shifter
cannot transform as many times as the
other Titans and his transformation
cannot be maintained as long so that is
my view despite the fact that there are
many humans beyond the walls something
that was not known at the beginning of
the series it seems like Levi can still
keep his title as humanity strongest
soldier and that is it for today's video
I really hope you enjoyed it if you did
definitely smash that like button to let
me know and give the subscribe button
a colossal smash and ring that magic
YouTube belt so you don't miss future
videos if there's a character you really
want to see broken down next let me know
in the comments it can be a character
from attack on Titan or another anime -
this is the first time I did this type
of video so I would appreciate if you
let me know how you felt about it if you
want even more content follow us on
Instagram and Twitter at anime uproar
where the fun continues finally thank
you for watching I appreciate the
support and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you